street it's that lack of self-worth this
identifying yourself as a complete and
total failure it's very difficult
difficult to escape that especially when
you compare yourself to these people
that you know they show up for work at
their Tech job and they have this normal
existence and they're all looking down
on you and yes treating you with this
disrespect right and you're living in
the streets it's cold it's rainy it's
whatever you're obviously worthless yes
there's nobody that's reinforcing the
fact that you have any self any worth at
all right
it's just going to take you down further
and it's probably come from your
childhood of being treated as worthless
and abused and yeah but you ask me like
how I can go down to Skid Row and do
this I've done it every day for over
three years
I think the fact that I I am not tempted
by these things
like you could put crack Fentanyl and
crystal meth right here and they they
would sit here for three weeks and I
wouldn't even touch them what about four
weeks four weeks is when I came in